[Music]
firing practice for ukrainian soldiers
far away from the front line
[Music]
they've come to the uk to hone their
skills on solsby plane
but this is no ordinary war game
these troops are heading back to ukraine
to fight russia for real
the ability to use long-range guns could
prove vital
the sense of urgency makes them the most
dedicated of students for their trainers
a mix of soldiers from britain
and also new zealand
yeah we definitely see the high degree
of motivation and dedication to the
defense of ukraine and these guys they
are committed to the training they don't
take many breaks they certainly get
involved
they have no choice as these first
pictures of their training taken last
weekend show
the ukrainian troops are those in the
black vests and helmets they didn't want
to speak on camera
these soldiers are locked in a war with
russia yet they've come here to solsby
plane for training on weapons that they
believe will be key in helping to turn
the tide in the conflict
these old guns with a range of seven
miles were bought by the uk to be gifted
to ukraine
[Music]
but this is the kind of weapon that
could make the big difference
a multiple launch rocket system which
can hit a target more than 50 miles away
ukrainian soldiers are being trained on
these too
their hunger to learn and their need to
take risk meant a more slow and steady
approach to teaching was quickly ditched
it came as a shock to us we we prepared
the training program and the training
content based on our experience uh
delivering training to british soldiers
and when we found out that they were
professional rocket artillerymen um the
content of the course and delivering
that became much easier
britain has trained hundreds of
ukrainian troops in the past few weeks
and is about to coach many thousands
more
new support for ukraine is a key theme
for nato allies meeting this week in
madrid under the shadow of russia's war
prime minister boris johnson is using
the summit to announce another one
billion pounds of military aid that
ukraine's president while grateful for
the west's assistance has warned that
the allies must do more to help his
country win
back on solsby plane the ukrainian
soldiers say their new skills will help
them as they return to the fight
after this brief change of scene
debra haynes sky news madrid